to Johnson crafting the through Pass
real charts well this place is
absolutely jumped in water finish and
water staging this much video game
releases in is in full swing and as with
every year we have two new for all games
OH fifa and PES of course to juggernauts
and i am tomorrow saying i am joined by
what my voice there i am joined by
longsuffering Bristol City fan Yin
resident football expert soccer expert
Oscar dais suffering is the right word
yes hello Tom how you so you've played
and reviewed both PES and FIFA for our
website you can read about those on
games for calm and Cartman what scores
you gave them but I watched you play and
it seemed like you were mostly enjoying
both of them but with different elements
with each one yeah absolutely yeah
I think overall I prefer PES this year
but they both have their own strengths I
think to simplify it it comes down to
style versus substance
I think FIFA absolutely has the edge on
the style side it looks really really
good but I prefer the way PES feels
actually on the pitch right so I'm told
disclosure I am a very casual fifa and
PES player I don't play them religiously
I play them enough to be able to you
know have a conversation about them if I
need to which given my friends circle I
often need to so we're gonna break down
the various elements of each game and
kind of pit them against each other and
try and figure out what works for you as
a football game player so as you said
just now presentation is a big deal in
football games and in this respect one
is clearly edging the other one out
absolutely yeah
FIFA there's no question looks a lot
better than PES the most obvious side of
that is the licences PES doesn't have
the official licenses for most of the
world's leagues and top teams has a few
here and there but by and large it
doesn't have many Premier League teams
licensed it doesn't have many valley gir
teams licensed and at times that can
kind of make it it's not authentic right
it feels like that
whereas FIFA obviously does have that
and even stuff like FIFA has like the
official graphic overlays for the
Premier League and La Liga
the commentary is better in FIFA the
menus are nicer in FIFA there's
everything about it feels a lot more
polished
whereas PES feels quite raw and it has
also that stuff isn't changing really
year-on-year it's it's starting to feel
a little bit stale now I'm certainly off
the pitch in terms of that sort of
polished package FIFA definitely edges
it right and for someone like me who is
a kind of casual player the presentation
element of it the more it looks like a
broadcast football match the more
inclined I am towards it as you know
this year it doesn't not being able to
pick up a controller and figure out
which one is Manchester United Liverpool
etc for people like me is kind of like a
deal breaker in a lot of ways which is
why we're kind of making a big deal
about the fact that PES has
significantly less interesting
presentation than FIFA absolutely
obviously gameplay is where it matters
and how do those two stack up to each
other in that respect I mean FIFA in
terms of gameplay is definitely improved
over last year I thought fever 17 was
probably on the pitch I thought is the
worst FIFA in a long long time
I think FIFA 18 does bring it back up
again it's a small improvement but it's
definitely an improvement it does feel a
little bit tighter the responsiveness is
a little bit better the dribbling is a
little bit better the shooting is quite
a lot better actually shooting feels a
lot better than it does than it did
previously and crossing as well and
those actually feel satisfying to use
now you don't feel like at times last
year it felt like you were fighting
against the controls it felt like you
were really sort of having to wrestle
with the controller to do what you
wanted to do on the pitch whereas now it
feels a little bit more natural yes so
FIFA seems to be kind of regaining
ground instead of short you know
breaking new one whereas pairs from what
you wrote about and what you've been
telling me about and what I've seen and
played it's kind of like a step forward
for the franchise
definitely yeah again it's I think it's
a minor step I don't I don't think it's
a huge leap forward that we saw with PES
16 for example but yeah is it's again a
small improvement if it's weird how both
of these games are slowing down and
pairs in particular feels a lot
last year it feels responsive like that
I think that's a large part of why it
feels so much better is because your
inputs are immediately shown on the
pitch where as FIFA it feels like
there's like just a split second of
input delay and that kind of feels again
like it makes it feel like you're
wrestling against the controller whereas
PES is definitely a lot more responsive
yes from what you've what from what I've
seen it does seem like PES has a little
more energy behind everything whereas
whereas FIFA feels like it's a bit stop
and start when you're moving the ball
around or even trying to make a break or
something like that
so from that's just from me watching and
not playing that much but it seems like
either what you're saying is either way
you'll get a good football game in terms
of gameplay but the one that's really
going to be rewarding as you put in more
time which is what people do with these
games they play for a year until the
next one comes out out of those two PES
is probably the you know the more
gratifying or the - yeah definitely
weirdly that's sort of swapped around
when you when you come to look at the
modes that are on offer in each game PES
is big new mode this year is random
selection mode which is a really good
party game like it's not a mode that you
can sit there and play by yourself for
hours and hours and hours it's a mode
that you play a couple of times with a
mate or with a group of mates so
basically it is really hard to describe
but basically you get handed a random
selection hence the term random
selection mode a random selection of
eleven players and you can essentially
secretly hick which of your opponent's
players you want to steal off of them
and they can do the same for you and you
can also pick a player that you want to
keep you want to protect and they do the
same but you don't know who each of
viewers picked and so it creates this
really amazing mind game of I want to
get his best player but they might have
chosen protected their best players so
do I want to go for their second-best
player but then they might second-guess
me so it creates this amazing mind game
where you might end up nicking their
best player and it feels so good when
you do that and it's really hilarious
the big ones certainly for the--for his
ultimate team like that has become so
big now it's almost a game in and of
itself but there's so many different
ways to play Ultimate Team the big new
addition towards one team this year is
squad battles squad battles is actually
a single-player where you play a certain
number of games over the course of the
week
and you're ranked so they're all offline
games but you're ranked against other
real world players and how many games
you win and these offer the best offline
rewards that you can get an ultimate
team so it just continues to expand an
ultimate team really ass or whether the
longevity I think lies for fifa and PES
as alternative that is my club in its
it's an interesting alternative and it's
a different take on it like the way you
sign players is different you have sort
of scout cards that you combine rather
than searching for the transfer through
the transfer market but FIFA is sorry
PES is actually making ground in the
modes it's added a 3v3
online co-op mode this year which is an
attempt I think to try and rival FIFA's
pro clubs it's not at that level yet pro
clubs is a lot deeper and allows you to
play 11 V 11 rather than 3 B 3 but it's
definitely a step forward I think PES is
definitely making a lot grind up here
currently FIFA probably still has the
edge in terms of the Mo's that are on
offer mainly because of Ultimate Team
right in the modes so overall how would
you kind of if you had to tell people
who are kind of picking between the two
modes you know how to approach it I
think it depends mostly on how you're
gonna be playing these games if you're
gonna be like I tend to just play
football games by myself I like to come
home switch my brain off relax just have
a couple of games a fee for all pairs by
myself maybe in career mode or monitor
mode and I think if you're gonna do that
I think PES is the way to go because I
think you will get more enjoyment out of
the deep gameplay offering that it has
however I think if you're going to be
playing against your friends your
friends are more likely to be buying
FIFA and I think FIFA probably has the
edge and like I say in terms of Ultimate
Team and pro clubs it has more ways to
sort of interact so I think if you're
going to be more of a again air quotes
casual player
I think FIFA probably has the edge but
if you're going to be one who's gonna
sit there and play it for hours on end
all year long by yourself
I think PES offers definitely a more
rewarding experience so there you have
it that's our Oscars verdict on FIFA vs
as we said at the start of the video
you've reviewed both of these games you
can read those reviews on Gamescom
there's also quite a few gameplay videos
on the youtube channel youtube.com 4
slash GameSpot give those videos alike
we've also put the
switch version through spaces there's a
gameplay video of that up on the YouTube
page and I believe you'll be doing a
review of that as well as Roman so keep
your eyes out for their own games for
calm and you can find us on Twitter in
the meantime I'm at two more H and Oscar
is that they said come and tell him
about why he's wrong about FIFA PES and
we'll talk to you next time bye-bye
[Music]